engagement trappe citoyens liste d'union
locales menées par mustapha larbaoui
avec comme tête de liste
othman nassr ou présentent leur campagne
avec un programme autour de dix
engagements
parmi eux la réussite scolaire je
défends la même idée le retour à la
semaine de quatre jours nous le ferons
avec les parents d'élèves dont on a
toujours été solidaire il faut quatre à
plomber les mêmes chances de réussir
tailleur autre préoccupation la n 10 qui
coupent cette ville et le bruit routier
auquel plus de 8% des trappistes sont
exposés le candidat trouvent que le
projet d'enfouissement de la n10 n'est
pas aboutie je propose aussi de faire
évoluer ce projet par exemple avec d
enrobé phonique sur la nationale 10 là
aussi la région ile de france dans
laquelle je siège à financer des projets
de ce triple à
notamment à l'haÿ les roses et les
résultats sont extrêmement bon on divise
le bruit par quatre parmi ses autres
propositions la création d'une police de
proximité au service des habitants 24
heures sur 24
actuellement il existe une police
municipale composée seulement de huit
agents qui ne fonctionnent que la
journée c'est une intention ferme de ma
part renforcer la police municipale
triplera ses effectifs il faut qu'on
arrive à une police municipale de 30
agents et puis nous renforcerons la
vidéo protection autour notamment des
écoles et des commerces
batman nasri élu vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique depuis 2010 9
souhaite baisser le taux de chômage à
trappes qui est de 19% contre 12% sur
saint quentin en yvelines
la proposition que je fais aujourd'hui
sur la question de l'emploi et les
simples c'est de proposer aux trappistes
mille formation professionnelle
qualifiante qui débouche sur des emplois
des emplois des formations de courte
durée dans les métiers en tension
le programme de la liste engagement
trappe citoyen est aussi présentée dans
un livret de trente et une page